F
A LOT OF POLICE OFFICERS HERE.I.
VE>> IT IS ABOUT TO BEH MORE
USE WE'RE GOING  RAISE OUR FIRSS
BUT FIRST WEEED TO PAY T BET WHO
PASED AWAYT AGE
RY 17th S GOINh BIRTHD.WHAT AED.
N  I1939. SO.
>> OF HER FIRS SHOWS
-SHE WAS
CO-HOSTING WITH LEFT, SH
5 1/UROF LIVON.
TV IT WACALLED.OLLYWOOON
5 1/2 HOUR LIVSIONSIX DAYS A WE.
BEHIND THE SCENES PRODUCING HEO.
>> WE HAVE TWO GREAT WHI
E FROM THEAT SUE NIVAN
NS>> I WANT A JOB WH
HASMILE.
I DON'T LIKE SMILING ALL THE
AM?TURE. ANN, YOU'RE.
RIGHT NOW?
>> UH-HUH.
>> SOPHIA, WHAT ARYOUR DOING
WITH THAT HEAVY COAT ODEHOE?
>> YOU TELME
, WAS SOPHIA NAKED  OR DOES HERY
LADY.
>> LOVEL
WEG TO RAISE OST
YEAR'S EVE.N OE.
A LOT OFRE
NOT A LOT OFS
RTHAG.
T YOALL TOTH WHAIS
YOUR -- YOU'RE COMFORTABLES QUI.
THIS IS IN HONORWHITE.
A LIFEELLI
ARS OLD. WHITE
CHEER
HE.THERE YOU GO.
ER
WRE
DRINKI
I'VE GOT MORE FOR  REALLY? YES,
ED US N'T ALU
INT HAD -- TG K
THE LAST TIM>> DINNER F WEEKANO
WINE.
TIME TOGETHE
THIS YEAR.
AT
OF TIME TOGEVELYESWITH
>> SO MA
>> I'M GO SHOW A PICTU
'S E THIS PICTURE.
THIS IS WH MY SO- MY
PHON A- SORRY IT
CL
R BY.
T ALL OF THE BEN'S.
WERE AT THD OF A S CLOTHES, WE
ANYWAY.
SPENT SO MUCH TIME THER THIS WE
>> DID WE REALLY?
AD
PARTY.
LIKE, WHY DON'YOT  WLLS YOR BIR.
>> LOOK ATHE GALAXY OF. A MOMEN
GOON.
T -- TERRIBLE GIGIVER.
IT'S T ME BEAUTIL DECORATIVE
A DECORATIVE BOX.R
>> IT ISANTIQUE.
>> HAV S
>> IT'S SITTING ON M
>> HAVE A R DESK? ON
>> IS THAT N
>> IBRR MARCH -- JUST
DON'T READ THE FINE PRINT.T TOOE
REE ISROFOILING.HEA TRANSLOSENTS
THE WATER.
AND I AMHE
>> SO I DID THISREE
OOK HOW WHITE HE
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN -- H,T IS-
HE'SWFUL.>> IAWFUL DOING THAT I
YOU IN THEATER.LOVE IT.BOUTREAL.
I DIDN'T REALIZE IS I WAS
THROWING MBA
>>UCT LANDING.
>> I'VE NOT BEENBLE TO WORK
LITTLE IKEOUBRUARY OF
THANKS FOR
REATHISTHE REAL HSERN 15 IS
>> ISN'T THAINED
15 YEA OLD.>> NONOMEN LA DA
OVER 30. F WF TH
EALLY CATCH ONTO I YLIKE YTHING
CRIME FRANCHE.
OWOF THESEWIVES
HAVE NOW BEER
HUSBANDS?
>> THANK YOU.
, .
>> YOUAID IT'S TURNING INTO
TRUE CRIME.
>> I MAKING T
>> I A TOO.
CHARGED WITHI>> HAS SHENVICTEDH
OR -- MAYWAY.
>> TRIAL IN MARCH?U GOING TO CO
.I JUST GOT OVER S I AY AD COVI
OPPORTY  OF
WEDIOLRY.TOP.LL STORY ABOUT WHEU
>> IT'S FUNNY.
>>L AND
- SH
YOU HAO GO ON  AND T URNUMBER -
>> CORRESPA
PRISONER, SOMEU KNOW A LOT
AND THE SUBJECNE OF EVERY
EMAIL WAS,SA.
I LOGGED OIAL SIYWAY.
REHEY ONE DANB PRISON.
THINGS I'VE NEVER SEEN THAI
WAS SO EMBARRASSED THAI'
. GODFATHER."
>> I CAN'TELEVER
EN
THE AT AHERE ANYTHING YOU'EVYORE
D OF MUSIC."F
C.>> IE SEEN - YOU CY CARIGHT N.
PETER PAN."GOING TO UNRICUYS GEE
WIN, ER LOOKI O, STARINT N IN
AND SINGIN
I FEEL IT'S KIND OTH THING.
SHNGETS W
CORRPO WORLD.
>> CHLOEON
WERE JUST SUPPOSED TO EOLE  NEW
BE INTRODUCI IT AN THE
WHOLWHOLE INWENT ANDERSON, Y CHE
TOGETHER.E SPENT FOUR HOURS
XCITED HER D NOW.
TIERRST  MYSELIN NEWYEAR.
ODY IS SO
PEOPM AL.
AND M GOINTOOUF TH.
WHERE ARU ?
ENGLAND.
>> HOW LONVE YOU BEEN
STANDING OUTE? SEVEN>> WHO ARE
SEE? K TO BE PERING  BROADCA
WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
>> S.TH
>> NO,T'S NOT MY F TIME HE?
T FIRST TIME FOR -- XCITED?O EX.
>> AND THEY HOME STATE
OF TEXAS --
>> WE'RE FROM BR
TEXAS.
>> HOW EXCITED TO BE HERE?
O EXCITED.
DO YOU GUY NEW YS?R
>> TO BEONEST WITH YOUNONDE U F?
>> C AWEVE.
WHO ARE YOU